individuals who have a stronger drive to
find mates are more likely to want to
play violent video games and to play
them more often I never would have
thought it actually would have worked
out if it didn't keep showing up
constantly in our studies
why do people play violent video games
what's their motivation
that is an age-old question since video
games really came out isn't it
um you know
they're fun first off let's be honest
they're a really good time and people
love playing them
but that's not really enough of a an
answer is it it's um seems like there's
more than that just driving us and you
know my research and the research of my
colleagues Tom Denson for example
um we believe that it's a search for
status
video games really allow you to test
your medal against others
and they allow you to see how well you
stand up to other folks and as a
consequence it allows you to see how you
stack up and where you sit in a
hierarchy so we're arguing that it
really allows you to get a better
understanding of yourself and where you
sit in between others
why the violence yeah well if we look
through at human history you know
there's not a lot of kindness or as much
kindness going on as there is kind of
aggression and violence and if we look
at all animals all almost all animals
have some kind of social hierarchy and
individuals in the top of that hierarchy
have you know extra or gain more
benefits than other individuals lowering
that in that hierarchy
and violence is a way to kind of keep
that order in that hierarchy and it
actually a hierarchy works really well
because
we are able to understand where we sit
and when we know where we sit we
actually don't have to compete against
one another and we don't have to be
violent against one another
it's when that hierarchy is kind of
removed do we find that that there's
disorder and individuals within that
system need to figure out where they sit
and that's when more aggression usually
happens
so we have this kind of interesting
system in video games where individuals
play games to have fun but also can
compete against one another can kind of
see where they stand against one another
and that allows everyone to constantly
keep changing and testing where they sit
in that hierarchy so we see a lot of
kind of an attraction to violent video
games because of that I had a researcher
called Tony Volk on the show recently
and he did some stuff around bullying
one of the interesting insights that he
gave me was that bullies need to bully
somebody who could be conceivably within
a similar status hierarchy because if
it's a 12 year old bullying a
five-year-old you what's what's the
status here or the same thing the same
thing if it's a fight between two guys
in the street but one of them's got a
baseball bat and the other just has his
hands
that also isn't a particularly reliable
measure of status because you don't have
two people it's why there's no status
associated with some young guy punching
an old lady like there's no uh
competition for hierarchy when it comes
to that and presumably one of the things
that you get with games this is
interesting thinking about games like
um fortnite and uh Call of Duty Warzone
what they've done is the only real
upgrades he I guess was and slightly
different but the only real upgrades
that you get especially on fortnite uh
artificial aesthetic ones so you're not
getting anything that gives anybody an
advantage in the game every single game
of Battle Royale on fortnite the playing
field is completely flat and it is how
good are you from the beginning to the
end best man wins a woman
person exactly absolutely and and that
is key isn't it because if you have an
advantage then there's a problem it's
really hard to say what what caused you
to win or to lose oh well you know I
lost that game because that person you
know spent a lot of money to be able to
get those upgrades so of course I was
gonna lose
and that's that's a really interesting
question as well because winning and
losing we know have effects in a lot of
different animals
and we are starting to see that same
kind of research being done on humans
which is really neat you have this loser
effect where if you lose you're more
likely to lose in another game
uh in a future game that you play if you
win you're more likely to win in a
future game that you
if those odds are are stacked against
you does that winner effect have the
same effect or that loser effect have
that same effect on your perception of
yourself and how you behave in a future
match you know for example if if I'm
playing someone like we talked about in
Warzone and they have you know a much
better gun than I do but we're equal in
all other parts I'm going to end up
losing and when I end up losing I'll say
to myself wow I didn't lose because I'm
really terrible at this game I lost
because that person had an advantage so
it's unlikely that that's going to have
that same kind of effect on my
self-perception of my own ability as a
real loss where we're equals so
absolutely you know fighting within your
status or closer to your status likely
has a much bigger effect but there's
actually very very little research done
on that kind of stuff which is kind of
interesting so it's an open playing
field
so if we look at a lot of non-human
animal research that's where we've done
a lot of research on what happens to
losers after they lose and what happens
to Winners after they win and in those
systems we see a really unique kind of
pattern where it's not them necessarily
adjusting things as far as we can tell
it seems to be some kind of internal
response for example let's imagine two
crickets fighting for some space where
they're going to call for some females
to try and attraction females and make
with them
you'll have males fight pretty
aggressively for that space if that
fight escalates to something that's
really physical where they have to be
really aggressive with one another and
there's a chance of them hurting with
hurting one another then what happens is
that the winner ends up
it's almost as if he feels better about
himself but that's a very human way of
thinking about it
um but comes out of that fight and if
you match that individual with another
male of the same size and same traits
they end up out competing that male they
have a better chance of winning than if
they bought them for the first time
and it's vice versa for the loser the
loser will go into another fight and if
you match them for the same size and the
same weight and all those traits they're
more likely to lose that fight than they
that second fight after they win after
they lost
so it's not necessarily
it but it seems as if something's going
on internally so in a lot of systems
we've looked at physiology maybe there's
some hormonal changes of what's going on
and that's shifting how individuals
perceive themselves but there's no real
clear kind of pattern across and the
animal kingdom and when you look at it
in humans it's even more complex so
we've not figured that out at all and
there's still a lot of research to keep
looking into it's so strange when the
Matthew principal and paulos end up
appearing in nature as well I wonder
you know there's John Peterson stand up
straight with your shoulders back thing
about the lobsters and serotonin and and
yeah like that
um but especially when it comes to a
computer game
I don't know you know you don't think
that it's quite as limited by
let's say that there's some sort of
hormone Cascade that stops people
people's muscles from being able to
deploy power in the same way if you're a
loser right or or you are beaten in a
fight so you spend the next couple of
weeks further down the status hierarchy
which means that your malnourished and
undefared and depressed which means that
the next fight that you get into but
you're iterating so quickly in video
games that you you're almost controlling
for the physical uh changes so it makes
me think that at least in humans a lot
of it has to be about self-perception
and about the story that we're telling
ourselves
I think so too because if you think
about when you're talking about
physiological or hormonal shifts that
are happening within our body and you
mentioned that if we go down the status
hierarchy then we're going to experience
less interaction less food potentially
become more depressed that's really
really costly if that was built into our
system you can see that being selected
out from an evolutionary perspective
really quickly because that's really bad
if you can't survive after losing well
then
it's going to be hard for you to find a
mate and you know have your genes
continue on for the population you would
end up producing or selecting for a
exhalation of people who are immune to
losses that's exactly it so it doesn't
seem like it's that simple I and I do
agree with you because I do think
personally that it is something about
self-perception and this is a really
hard thing to test in non-human animals
which is why I've moved to humans to
kind of explore this question but it's
also really hard to look at in humans
especially in the video games that we
currently play because game designers do
something really interesting right they
kind of balance wins and losses for you
because if you keep winning and you
realize I'm really good at this game
then all of a sudden you don't really
want to play anymore because that
challenge is kind of gone
the same thing if you end up losing a
bunch of matches over and over again you
end up not wanting to play because you
realize you're not very good and it's no
longer any fun
so designers are balancing that so when
you first start playing a game they
match you to people who have your level
you know if you win something they might
match with someone more difficult where
you end up losing so you end up going
down that self-received hierarchy but
then you they match with someone who's a
little bit worse than you and you end up
winning so they're balancing those wins
and losses for you so you're always kind
of in that sweet spot and you're always
wanting to kind of play
so that's why it's actually really
really hard to use current video games
to explore these outcomes
because it's not just what's happening
to us it's under the system is
uncontrolled by the game designer so
it's really hard to tease those aspects
apart you also looked at uh demographic
status related and mating related
correlates to playing video games right
yes so I I've always been fascinated
with this kind of outcome because I
never expected you know our desire to
want to attract mates or to interact
with the opposite sex or potential
sexual partners
as a driver to want to play video games
but it really predicts it really well
consistently and that's for both men and
women individuals who have a stronger
drive to find mates are more likely to
want to play violent video games and to
play them more often
which is I never would have thought it
actually would have worked out if it
didn't keep showing up constantly in our
studies
why what's going on yeah
so if we go back to that idea of a
hierarchy again individual is hot up in
that hierarchy have access to more mates
you have access to more potential
Partners uh you have access to more
resources and individuals who are
wanting access to those things wants to
keep getting up in that hierarchy so are
driven to kind of play more violent
video games because once again that
gives you that feedback of where you
stand within that social system if you
keep winning and you're doing really
well then you know your or you perceive
yourself as a better individual even if
the is just in video games it kind of
reflects your self-perception of your
own ability in other aspects so and what
does it say that the people who are most
status seeking in the virtual world
pursue a particular thing which actually
leads to relatively few successes of
status in the real world like it seems
to me if if you are looking to be
successful uh sociosexually
winning at fortnite is not the most
direct route to go down so it seems
almost like this desire for status and
esteem and prestige in the eyes of the
opposite sex and your own sex has been
hijacked in a way which doesn't actually
realize many of the gains that you
should do is that fair
it is and if we think about what you
just said you know the virtual world in
the real world that Line's blurring very
very quickly you know what is the
virtual world now what is the real world
um and if we look through our
evolutionary history this virtual world
never existed so our systems evolve the
response of the real world and just like
you said developers are able to kind of
hijack that whole system and we seem to
not be able to tell the difference
between how a win occurs in the virtual
world and the real world those are both
very satisfying kinds of things and
allow us to kind of change our
self-perception of ourselves in response
to that win or loss oh so I understand
what you meant about the lines being
blood
uh individuals who play these video
games are struggling to distinguish
between successes in the virtual world
and successes in the real world I
wouldn't say that you're able to cash in
status from being good at video games as
effectively in the real world now I
would be interested to see if you looked
at people who are who have more
followers uh on uh media platforms who
post more frequently
um who use items in their captions and
in tweets and stuff more frequently I
would guess that you will find basically
the same effect going on but that is
complete bro signs
well if that's an interesting one as
well right because you're self-selecting
for uh a group of individuals who are
doing really really well or not only
status seeking but they're doing really
really well in that environment and are
really high in that hierarchy so
possibly but it's it's hard to tease
apart kind of what's going on but if we
go back to just something you said just
before that I don't think necessarily
that
it's a concern that these virtual skills
transfer into the real world
I don't think our minds kind of think in
that kind of a way even though there are
some studies showing that performance in
certain video games actually does
translate into greater performance in
the real world in a work context uh like
when you're playing games like SimCity
and managing games you're actually seem
to be much better at managing projects
and and doing work in a team in the real
world so interestingly enough some of
those skills do translate but I don't
necessarily think that
someone who's playing war zone a lot and
they're killing it in that game and they
step out and go man I am just so
incredible
they realize that those skills don't
translate to anything real but they
still feel really good about themselves
and if we know about trying to gain
friends and trying to gain mates we know
confidence is a really strong thing and
if that interaction online improves your
confidence your self-confidence that is
going to translate to some real world
kind of benefits do you have any
evidence for that
there isn't much right now because this
is a kind of a new way of thinking
I would be so fascinated to see if that
works so I'm I'm currently of the
opinion that that the almost the
opposite thing happens so
um
it's my belief that screens video games
and porn are sedating men out of their
status seeking uh team bonding and
reproductive Fitness behavior that
they're given a titrated dose right just
a tiny tiny little amount The Uncanny
evolvers as they're called by Diana
Fleischmann
um and what this is doing is it's
causing young male syndrome which we
should have seen given the amount of uh
matelessness and sexlessness and
loneliness that young men particularly
are suffering with at the moment that's
the reason that young male syndrome
hasn't kicked in that men are being
sedated out of these behaviors by this
but what you're suggesting if this is
true
is that confidence and Status that's
derived in the virtual world would cause
people to believe that more readily in
the real world now what would be
surprised the reason that that would be
surprising to me is that we're seeing
people Retreat from Real World behaviors
that would have been predicted had they
have found success in the virtual world
and it crossed over more and more we're
seeing people Silo themselves off just
into an online world that doesn't come
back across now this could be due to
something that isn't just status
hierarchies you know about this
could be the generalized addictive
nature of these uh of these tools it
could be the Comfort crisis or
convenience the fact that the couch is
just way more comfortable
um but yeah what's what's your thoughts
on that male sedation hypothesis all of
this stuff I've just thrown in
yeah those those ideas have been around
and I listen to them a lot and
it seem like really simple answers to me
to a very very complex problem I don't
think it's that simple and I don't think
it's any of one of those things that are
causing individuals to kind of behave in
that in that way
um and here let me explain explain why
first off as a scientist one thing I
learned really early in my career is
everything is really complex way too
complex to actually simplify in these
single or one or two or even three
different kind of factors second
with you earlier we talked about this
idea that individual individuals who are
more interested in sex and finding
partners are more driven to play violent
video games because they're more driven
for status right
interestingly what else explains this
Behavior or what else is correlated with
this Behavior playing Violet video games
if you're is your own self-perception of
your own make value
if you perceive yourself as a high
quality mate you end up playing more
violent video games
then we started manipulating that could
we actually change an individual
self-perception of themselves and what
do they do afterwards
so what we did is we took a bunch of
individuals and we ended up letting them
play different video games some were
Violet and some were non-violent and we
looked at their performance in those
games
individuals in the non-violent games
they didn't change their self-perception
of their own ability and performance and
that didn't seem to affect their own
self-perception of their main value
but individuals who performed really
badly in the violent video game
saw themselves
as worse off
exactly they actually decreased their
own self-perception of their make value
which I think is fascinating that a
video game can actually do that to
somebody and you didn't see this in
non-violent video games that's correct
it was uh mediated less
it we didn't even see it
wow so yeah
to recap violent video games are able to
contribute to self-perceived make value
non-violent video games are not able to
elicit the same effect however this
could be could how much of this could be
a selection effect that the people who
want to play video games are the type of
people whose status and self-perception
of make value would be impacted by
playing that right okay I I understand
absolutely and and that and you can see
how complex that can be and then now it
could if he's taken to the next step
there are individuals who prefer certain
styles of games what happens when you
match that style of game with that
individual's personality do we see more
of our lesson effect so you can see all
all of a sudden things are stacking up
to make things really really complex but
there's another little addition to the
story of a paper that we're actually
writing up so I'll give you a little bit
uh
kind of some
some early news on on how things are
looking on this and something will
probably be submitted very soon
what we did is we took a few
undergraduates both men and women uh at
our University and we asked them to come
in
and we told them where
working on a dating study we were really
interested to see what young people are
looking for in potential Partners
um would you like to help us with the
study and they inevitably do
um and then we did this kind of a neat
experiment where we had a TV in front of
them and we said we're going to allow
you to talk to someone just virtually
because we're looking at online dating
and we want to see how you interact with
that individual and that individual is
going to meet somebody else and then
they're going to choose a potential
coffee date with one of you so at the
end of the day what we're doing is we're
doing we're allowing individuals to
compete for a potential mate and they
win or lose that opportunity right
so with that individual that's on screen
that they're talking to that's actually
a recording so it's never going to
happen they're never going to meet
somebody but that individual is
attractive and fun and bubbly and they
want to end up dating that individual
then what we do is we provide them with
an envelope that says yes or no that
they ended up getting that coffee day
and we didn't know what result they
received so that was completely
randomized for us
the fun thing comes to what we asked
them to do after that so they were given
that envelope they opened it and they
were given that coffee date they were
not given that coffee date
and then we asked them
uh thank you so much for being part of
this study if you don't mind we just
need to kind of finish things up but
we're actually starting a new study in a
few weeks and this is actually going to
be exploring about video games and what
video games people like to play
um we have six games here and we're
trying to figure out if these are good
games that we should show folks can you
let us know which one you'd like to play
and then you have an opportunity to play
it and test it out for us
three of those games were violent video
games and three of them were not violent
video games and I have a feeling you
know where this might be going
the individuals that ended up or men
that ended up losing that coffee date
were more likely to want to play a
violent video game while individuals
that won that coffee date were more
likely or less likely to play a violent
video game
so after that competitive mate loss
individuals shifted their preference of
what they wanted to do and our argument
was they ended up wanting to the losers
wanted to play more violent video games
because it allows them that opportunity
to regain that status that they ended up
losing in that sexual interaction
so interesting man it's fun isn't it
it's so much fun to be able to see how
people interact in that kind of a system
and that's why I think video games are
so powerful in a way that we can explore
some really interesting questions and I
don't think they've been used in the
best kinds of ways dude I mean let's say
let's say that you managed to get a
research
um partnership with fortnite or with
Warzone I know and you would be able to
do things like have a front-facing
camera detect micro Expressions on
people's faces you'd be able to look at
uh what's reaction what happens to
reaction time and then you could get yes
some you know chemist or some biology
biology dude to come in and have a look
at what the hormones do how is Reaction
Time mediated what about eye pattern
movement is there more lateral up down
eye pattern movement what does that
suggest about someone's brain State yeah
I mean we you know you could get an
awful lot
um absolutely an awful lot of
information just to round out the
um
video games discussion when you give
people the opportunity of choosing these
different games and you're saying people
who are more
preoccupied that are more concerned with
status specifically mate seeking as one
of those
what is the personality trait that you
think is driving that is it
socio-sexuality is it externalizing
behavior is it extroversion what is it
uh to be honest I'm not sure if there's
a single trait
um I don't think it maps to the big five
that well also I think it varies in an
individual's lifetime
um you know I think there's definitely
feedback in in our in our own personal
experiences that potentially influence
those outcomes that changes our
personality it changes our outcomes that
changes our likelihood to behave in
certain ways like a mechanism yeah yeah
so again you know I don't think it's
that simple that we can just go ahead
and say you know extroverted individuals
are more likely to play these games
they're more likely to get that that hit
of what they need that self-perceived
increase in mate value you know they see
them higher in their hierarchy and they
behave that way so if we hit those
individuals we get a better
understanding of what's going on I think
it's a lot more complex
um but I do think we can start using
video games and that feedback
individuals gain from video games to
better understand why certain people
continually are drawn to that and become
addicted to video games as we know it
okay uh other question from earlier you
gave people the opportunity to choose
between violent and non-violent video
games
have you got any suggestion or is there
any evidence that suggests that people
who are more preoccupied with status
full stop play video games more not that
yes yet a bucket of Gamers and then
Gamers move within that does it make
them more likely to pay video games full
stop
I I do think that is a status seeking
individual who are more driven to play
violent video games because what we do
end up seeing as well as a very very
strong age effect we know that
um
you know our our desire for sex kind of
decreases over time as we age
as that happens we are less interested
in gaining status
because we just don't need it as much
any longer because we're not
trying to achieve those hierarchical
kind of goals so I do strongly believe
that individuals who are more status
seeking are going to end up wanting to
play more violent video games uh and
then as a result you end up getting that
feedback so there may actually be
something in those individuals who do
become addicted
our thinking is and this is something
that still needs to be tested our
thinking is that it's individuals who
aren't getting that satisfaction with
their own status that are constantly
being driven to want to go play violent
video games and that is that bizarre
feedback loop that keeps getting people
in into violent video games
um when they should stop isn't it
strange that the cohort of people that
we think about when we think about
compulsive uh High hour violent video
games users would be you know your mum's
basement in cell Retreat from society
guy yeah but these people it seems are
more preoccupied with sex and Status
they're more preoccupied with gaining
prestige in the eyes of the people
around them and I wonder whether what
we're seeing you know the last 10 years
or so we have seen the prevalence of
some misogynistic Echo Chambers online
uh of guys who spend an awful lot of
time on the internet uh very very
carefully nitpicking and breaking down
what's happening within the dating
Market uh why women perhaps don't care
about them I would guess if you were to
look at some of the black pill and incel
forums that a lot of those guys would be
very heavy violent video game users
this is this is you know you're talking
to one of my favorite studies that I've
ever written you know why are
individuals behaving in kind of sexist
aggressive ways to women online this is
a study I did a while back and um
with a colleague Jeff kuznikov all right
and if and if you give me a second to
tell that story I'd love to tell it
um yeah Jeff is Jeff did an incredible
PhD
um where he ended up playing about 500
games of Halo uh back in the day when it
was really really popular and I you know
I've told this story and everyone was
like oh man I wish I could do that for a
PhD uh and it was it was incredible what
he did
with those 500 games
a third of them he played
as himself with a male voice that he
would just press buttons to respond to
individuals in game
and that would say different phrases to
colleagues to teammates right because
you can't speak to your opponents so
it's important to say these are all
teammates
he played another third of those games
where he didn't talk at all
and another third of those games where
he used a female voice when he pressed
those buttons a female voice would you
know comment on anything that's going on
in the game
so you have these two treatments in a
control
and what you end up doing is he ended up
playing the game really really well
because he was actually quite good at
Halo at that time uh or he played it
kind of haphazardly where he didn't try
as hard
and he found that he got a lot more
negative comments to himself from his
teammates when he used a female voice
significantly more and this goes back to
that whole sexist kind of perception
what's going on there why are men being
aggressive towards women I read this
paper and I said Jack these are
incredible data have you ever looked at
what who is saying those negative
comments because if you look at your
positive comments men and women are gay
your male and female voice treatments
are getting the same number of positive
comments as well so it's just that
manner more aggressive towards women
before you go into the next bit where
you got involved yeah how much did his
performance mediate whether he was
playing well or badly he said that he
would he would either be lackadaisical
or successful how did that mediate
people's responses to the male and
female voice
a little bit but not nearly as much as
the treatments so the the factors that
affected
the kinds of comments he received were
largely explained by the treatment much
more than his own performance the
treatment the male voice or the female
right right okay okay cool so that
explained
that was there was there any difference
for how very little very little it
almost nothing right because I would
have thought you know let's say just
spitballing I would have maybe assumed
that um a very competent male player
would have caused some ire and jealousy
but we also know that men's intersexual
bonding is very heavily based around
coalitional Warfare so if you've got
some guy that's an absolute killer on
your team
maybe some people will be jealous but I
would guess that a lot of the guys would
defer to The Prestige
definitely and and it's and it goes back
to that whole conversation we had about
a hierarchy we want to know
where we sit because where we when we
don't know where we sit in a hierarchy
it's actually very very stressful
because individuals lower in the
hierarchy know there's going to be
competition for that alpha position or
the the top few positions and it's a you
have to tiptoe around and it's really
stressful even for the individuals in
the top three for example who are
fighting for that hierarchy we know that
it's that's it's also very stressful
because you have to keep competing we
know that because we've seen that
research done in a lot of primates and
it's it comes out really really nicely
so when hierarchies are disrupted it's
actually bad for everybody including
Alpha uh and all the males so so it's it
would it be bad for let's say a chimp 15
to 20 to be fighting for status chimp
one to three uh a similarly effect it
even goes back up the chain as well
absolutely because if you imagine those
those top three males in that kind of a
situation they want to know who's first
and they're fighting no let's say the
top three let's say that one to 15 is
locked in and then right at the bottom
end let's say the package is completely
secure but then there is there's some
turbulence toward the bottom does that
still cause Cascades up and down no no
not at all at that point it's not really
the bottom the the bottom rungs of the
individuals that are determining what's
going up on top and that content those
contests happening between the bottom
individuals aren't as aggressive and
aren't as important right however I'm
going to guess that if one in three are
huge competing that 15 to 20 are still
Downstream ah so because yeah you don't
want to get in the way of an aggressive
male understood let me give you this
yeah so um
you'll be familiar and we'll get back to
the the video yeah
you'll be familiar with that um famous
graph that uh some manosphere creators
use to explain uh hypergamy and it
basically explains how the top guy can
date you could imagine you've got from
top to bottom number one to ten going
down on both sides both men and women
the top guy can date number one all the
way down to number ten the guy from
number five can date from number five
down to number ten and then from ten can
go across Tony Vault yes at uh bullying
researcher that I explained to you about
from the other week what he
seeing works is it isn't bullying if you
end up competing with somebody who is
higher in status than you that's just
straight up aggression right bullying
has to be done to somebody that's in
lower status so if you could imagine the
same sort of diagram that I'm talking
about here with the one to ten you
basically have a bullying range and the
higher your status the more people you
can bully the lower your status the
fewer people you can bully and what
you're saying here is that the higher up
the status of the person or the group
who are competing for status the uh
larger the downstream implications are
so let's say that uh you know number 10
and 11 and 12 are competing I would
guess that maybe 15 and 20 do get a
little bit of cascade down from that
yeah one two and three don't
yes you'll definitely see that kind of
an effect you'll see that cascading kind
of happen but it's also when getting
back to that bullying content comment
that you made those those few
individuals on the top they don't need
to bully this individuals really low
down because they're on top there's no
benefit to be gained for them to do that
it's the individuals in the middle of
the hierarchy who are likely bullying
individuals lower than them because they
have some status to be gained about that
if you're number one you're not going to
bully number 15. you gain nothing but if
you're number 10 you want to bully 15
because if you don't there's a potential
for that individual to rise up it might
be 14 and then 14 might be 13 and get
the fact that's not good okay so video
games you find out that this guy has
played 400 games he's split it up to
three buckets one's female one's male
one's no voice at all and you've said
wow this is fantastic did you look at
who was giving you these comments what
what how do you get involved in this
study so Jeff said I'd love to but you
know I'm I'm just moving universities I
got a new faculty position and I just
don't have the time I said well can we
work on this together because I think
this is what you've done is absolutely
fascinating and you know I think we
could look into what's going on and see
who's behaving in that kind of way
so he agreed and he was super kind to
share his data we transcribed everything
uh what everybody said
um and because Halo at the end of every
match you actually have a status screen
at the end right you know where you sit
uh how well you performed how many kills
you got how many deaths you got and your
performance relative to others right we
all love that screen because we love
seeing our kill death ratio right
um so we take a snap of that and we can
see how well everybody did now what we
can start looking at is who said what
to who and how well they did in the game
so we have a measure of status
and now we can see how an individual
status affected what they said
to Jeff when he played as a male
character or a female character
and remember there were no these were
all men that were playing there are no
women playing at that thought
and what we find is that men
who were playing against Jeff
and outperformed Jeff as a male were
kind to him they lots of positive
comments
Men Who
didn't who didn't perform as well as
Jeff so Jeff outperformed him as a male
fewer positive comments but still very
few negative comments
and that kind of makes sense that gets
back down to what we just talked about
Chris where men who are lower in the
order don't want to be aggressive to
someone who is better than them because
there's a hierarchy there there's a
chance that
that could turn out really badly for you
and even if it's a video game it's
digitally and virtually online you're
not going to interact with this
individual in the real world but we
still behave in that way because that's
how our systems have been selected for
to work this is just a new environment
that's happening
and of course when you're top there's no
need for you to be aggressive and mean
to people below so you're more
supportive because you want to help
those people up so that's what was
happening when Jeff
played as a male voice it's completely
different when you look at how Jeff
played when he was a female
so when Jeff played when he was a female
what happened is that men that
outperformed him were very positive and
supportive
which is really great to hear again
they're not losing any status by being
supportive to somebody who is not as
good as them
but it's the men who performed worse
than Jeff when he used a female voice
that were very very aggressive and
there's a beautiful correlation between
an individual's level and their
performance in the game the number of
kills they got in the game their kill to
death ratio and how aggressive they were
individuals that were of lower status
and perform more poorly were more
aggressive to Jeff as a woman than they
were to when Jeff was a man
why
it goes back to exactly what she we were
just talking about in this hierarchy if
you are
a level 15 male
in this game and there's a woman coming
up and she's outperforming you
not only
is she better than you meaning she's
higher status than you are
she is also knocking you down the total
poll
and if we think about what that means
for a man is
now I'm lower status Than I Used to Be
I've lost to a woman and I have fewer
potential mating choices in that
environment it's exactly what you just
said and the best way to make sure that
women don't compete in that kind of an
environment is to make them not want to
compete and how do you make them not
want to compete you'd be very very
aggressive towards them and you use
sexist slurs because you know that hurts
the most
I've been thinking for a long time about
some of the challenges of women's
overachievement in education and
employment and
the
fact that we've basically flattened the
playing field for maybe even not maybe
maybe even skewed it slightly toward
women in that it's mostly knowledge work
it's a brain based not a broad-based
economy uh conscientiousness you know
the ability to just sit in a seat and
not have ADHD and all the rest of it it
isn't as an advantage I wonder whether
you're seeing an increase in male to
female adversarial communication because
women are now playing in the status
hierarchy that previously would have
been siled off Just For Men and you have
two things going on which you hinted at
before first one is in the overall
hierarchy of status there are this many
hundred people thousand people in the
game in the com the company whatever
you've been slotted down one generalized
status anxiety right is is the first
thing but the second part is hypergamy
which is if you can get that specific
female herself
and drag her down a little bit perhaps
there's a chance that she might debut
because if there is too big of a
disparity and make value or status
there's no way that that woman's going
to look at you and if you can manage to
get your status to stand on the
shoulders of the insults that you've
thrown at her
perhaps she'll see you as a potentially
viable mate what do you think about that
what do you think about how the
flattened playing field for employment
and education uh could maybe be tied in
with what you've learned from video
games
you know absolutely if you think about
how the world has changed and that's you
know 100 years for example we've seen a
huge shift in what determines status
we've seen a huge shift in the traits
that are associated with individuals
performing well in in a certain
environment that's especially when
you're talking about like you said
working companies uh you know things
that don't require physical strength and
traits if we look historic
evolutionarily speaking if we look past
you know tens of thousands of years
we know largely that men and women did
have certain roles
um
but it's it's not even as important of
what men did and what women did
generally there was a female hierarchy
and there was a male hierarchy and
individuals competed within that
hierarchy correct it was intro sexual no
intersexual competition that's exactly
it right it's all happening within
and you're competing against the same
sex and
it's kind of straightforward
um and that's largely because whatever
Society you're in the society has
decided this is what men do this is what
women do sometimes there's overlap but
very little uh whatever that decision is
what you've just said is this flattening
is this idea that now men and women are
able to compete against one another
because they're trying to attain the
same things they're trying to attain the
same jobs they're trying to attain the
same status same house same car same
everything so now all of a sudden men
and women are competing for the same
things
um and that's problematic from an
evolutionary perspective because that's
not the kind of environment that we
generally grew up in and that's not how
our system has been selected for in an
evolutionary context to be able to deal
with this kind of stuff so when men see
women competing in this field it's
bizarre it may be a little bit different
and like we said it's the best way to
make sure is by negging them right if
you make them feel bad about themselves
and you feel better and then it allows
you to gain status and allows you to
potentially
or more mating opportunities open up for
you
but I think what needs to kind of happen
now is a cultural shift we have to start
understanding that that world where
those hierarchies were separate from men
and women are gone they no longer exist
they're never coming back
nor should they because in this world
that we live in now that high those
separate hierarchies are irrelevant they
don't matter anymore we're working
together
for the same things
so what has to happen is a shift in how
men think
it's not why is it bad to lose to a
woman
it doesn't matter it's nothing to do
with strength anymore it's nothing to do
with physical endurance or differences
in our physical bodies or hormonal
changes or physiology
those aren't limiting factors anymore it
doesn't matter how strong you are that
doesn't determine how good you are at
War Zone it's your reaction time it's
how quickly you can process information
and men and women do that equally
there's no difference in that so all of
a sudden we have a Level Playing Field
in that kind of a world for men and
women and women are starting to thrive
in it if we look at some of my research
women who play more violent video games
have a better self-perception of
themselves
so they are responding in a similar way
to men in response to desire for status
so we actually have less
fewer differences between us than we
think and we're really ready to admit
so getting back I think the idea is that
we have to change that cultural shift of
what it's like to lose to a woman it's
not bad to lose to him you're losing to
someone who's better than you and if you
want to be better then you just got to
try harder
how much of that do you think is culture
I I don't disagree I don't disagree that
it would be a good idea for status
hierarchies to be able to be uh like
gender non-specific that it doesn't
matter whether you lose to a guy or a
girl but I think it would be naive to
presume that this is all just culture
and that men can think their way out of
this we can't reprogram men's status
hierarchies you know this is very very
this is back in the brain right so
um I think I don't think that that would
be the case but yeah how much of this do
you think uh is
just straight up culture and how much of
this do you think is coming from
elsewhere
I don't think you can separate culture
from what's going on you know culture is
a strong part of what it is to be human
you can't just take that out and say
this is how humans behave this is what
the things are Let's ignore culture of
what's going on with it culture is part
of us and it determines
who we are it also evolves over time
so culture is changing we are changing
uh there is selection Evolution
happening now as we speak
so these are all these things are
intertwined and I and you you say we
can't think a way out of this it's true
we can't think our way out of this but I
think we also have to shift
the way we think of it there are rules
that we've made in society where we said
these things are unacceptable and we've
all decided in this kind of way so we
can't we shouldn't behave in those kind
of unacceptable ways
I think you know as a side we have to
start realizing that
it's not losing to a woman it's losing
to a person
um and status is no longer determined by
simply competing intersectionally we now
are we've opened the playing field and
we've shifted how our culture works
that's shifted how selection functions
that shifted how we behave and yes there
are those back of the brain stem kind of
behaviors but we're also human we are
also able to think quite logically and
we have to start using that ability to
be able to understand what's going on I
think stepping in to mediate the really
sort of negative
pathological manifestations of that
behavior is good but I I also you know I
sympathize with sympathize I I
understand why guys who are
um struggling within status and of women
are highly highly competitive you said
it yourself you know even 50 years ago
even 50 years ago you didn't absolutely
how long have women been in the
workplace properly 50 years maybe
something like that you know they've
only been in University they've only
been University for like properly for
about 30 years that's when they got to
about charity 25. so you know it's very
very novel for the guys that are out
there absolutely absolutely going back
to the uh
language and and the analysis that you
did of that
the successful males speaking to the
females within the video game were they
more or less complementary than when
they were speaking to the man
so we didn't see any differences there
and it was it would be hard to tease
apart
um
it's hard to tease that apart simply
because we didn't get enough individuals
repeat playing so we can't see how they
behaved in both of those environments
and there wasn't enough sample size too
much individual variation between
players to be able to say oh this is the
equivalent player across whatever right
okay I understand so you know getting to
that way of thinking that you're talking
about I'm really really interested in
what happens to those High status males
when they're playing really well
and they lose
how do they behave and they lose to a
woman how do they behave then wow
there's one of two ways it could behave
right they could be very confident in
their own status and when they lose to a
woman they could say brilliant well done
I know how good I am you did really
really well no problem
so they could still behave in that way
because they are high status males or
they could be these high status males
that have lost a woman at that stage and
now see themselves sliding down that
hierarchy
and they could become a more aggressive
and the only reason they didn't is
because they happened to out-compete
that woman so we haven't teased those
two things apart and I don't know how
those High status males would behave in
a situation where they lost to a woman
and I think that's a an interesting kind
of question that needs to be answered
I'm also interested to just find out
whether they are more benevolent to a
same-sex or an altersex because I've
seen some really interesting research
around the usefulness and protective
nature of benevolent sexism uh the
benevolence sexism is actually
psychologically very healthy uh it's a
predictor of men being more uh more
effective protective providers that they
have uh better view that women are
happier working for these sorts of men
they're happy being in a relationship
with these sorts of men that you know a
an excessive denial of sex differences
seems to be at the detriment of both
sexes and um the benevolent sexism thing
I'd be interested there
um what about any other domains that you
could you you know you're so excited by
this this video game studio is
fascinating to see lower status males
derogating females that out compete them
within a single status hierarchy with a
relatively flat competences or
opportunities at least you must have
kept your eyes peeled for other domains
that you saw a similar effect in have
you observed anything have you found
anything there you see really similar
kinds of results in the field of
computer science in the field of
Surgeons or medical science
and also in business it's that same kind
of response in that same kind of
behavior and that study cited quite a
lot in those fields
in studies where they've actually looked
at how individuals with high status in
business or medicine
uh behave towards women who are lower
status and and you see very very similar
kinds of behaviors so it does seem to
kind of translate into other worlds as
well
you also did something to do with
playing violent video games and
subjective fighting ability and
perceptions of men's toughness and
facial recognition yes what was what was
all of that yeah so
you know another way of thinking about
violent video games is they allow us to
practice
um they allow us to practice certain
skills that could be beneficial in some
kind of hierarchical encounter
you know if we think about environment
video games
there's really low cost to play you lose
it's no big deal
um not like compared to a physical fight
if you lose in a physical fight you're
likely going to be damaged and hurt uh
and that's a very very bad thing for you
right but in video games it's okay if
you lose it's not the end of the world
so it's almost like it's a way of
trading to see how well you can perform
that and see if you can up your status
at the same time you know it could be a
way for us to gain signals of what makes
a good competitor so we can make better
decisions when we go into that
competition like if I could for example
get a better understanding of when I'm
interacting with someone How likely they
are to fight that how like when are they
going to be most aggressive and I can
see those little signals in that
potential opponent
that's to my advantage right because
then I know how far to push somebody I
know whether I could potentially take
someone and those are all good things
so we wanted to see if any of those
kinds of behaviors gained from playing
video games could potentially spill over
to the real world and how we assess our
opponents or individuals
and kind of what we ended up and what
the way we did that maybe I should
explain a little bit more there is you
know we let them play
again
a violent game or a non-violent game
and then we put them through a small
number of tests where we look at how
well can you discriminate emotions
how well can you potentially
discriminate whether an opponent is
better or worse than you
and what we ended up finding was that
individuals who played that violent
video game
were less adept
at noticing someone's shift towards
anger
which we found really really interesting
and this is kind of opposite to what you
think
it seems that playing that violent video
game
pumped individuals up to such an extent
that they're worse off
being able to tell when someone
is angry at them
and you would think that's really really
bad because that could potentially lead
to more aggression which could
potentially lead you to getting hurt and
getting hurt is never a good thing
why why why would it be the case that
someone who has spent all of their time
working out whether they're about to be
attacked by this enemy
becomes when it it's time to
actually work out whether or not
someone's going to attack them
oh no it's it's crazy isn't it because
you wouldn't expect that but that's what
we see happening and the only thing that
we can think of because this this starts
diving into the realm of physiology
what's going on in there in your system
what's changed is are there testosterone
spikes are we seeing some kind of a
shift in how our body is functioning
that's changing our ability to
distinguish
uh how we perceive our opponents
something's happening there but it's not
something simple it does seem to be
something in the physiological realm
which is not something that we've been
able to explore yet could it be hey look
at me bro silencing your study uh I love
it let's do it could it could it be
could it be something to do with the
desensitizing to aggression
it may well be you know if we if we
think of ourselves in society I was a
good friend of mine uh Rob Brooks has
this great analogy if you're sitting in
a crowd of people you're very unlikely
to throw a water bottle at somebody
who's saying terrible things on stage in
some kind of a protest for example
um because you're not that kind of
person you don't want to hurt anybody
but
if someone else throws a water bottle
first does that change your likelihood
to do that how about if there's a second
or third or a tenth
now all of a sudden while other people
are doing it you know maybe I should
kind of join in so it does seem to kind
of there's a shift in what you perceive
as acceptable behavior and it does seem
that our previous kinds of interactions
are in some way coloring what we're
doing in the future
whether that is a physiological thing or
whether that is a self-perception thing
it's tough to say I think definitely
self-perception has something to do with
it I don't know the relative importance
to something underlying physiological
and that's kind of what we're missing
for that puzzle what about the
subjective fighting ability and the
perceptions of toughness as well how is
that mediated
yeah individuals who
you know play those violent video games
did see themselves as tougher and we did
another study
to kind of push that and see what
exactly is going on there and in that
same kind of a way that I talked earlier
about how men responded to losing or
winning that coffee date we did a very
similar study where we were told we told
individuals you're going to compete
physically in a bunch of physical
challenges against another opponent and
that opponent is either stronger or
tougher sorry or weaker than you
and we found that individuals who were
more likely to compete against that
tougher individual were more likely to
want to play a violent video game
so it does seem that these opportunities
to become aggressive even in a virtual
world there's options to practice
aggression and dominance in a virtual
world is spilling over to real world
behaviors and our desire to kind of how
we know how we see our opponents
and that real world is then you know
filtering back into the virtual world
and shifting how we want
what we want to do in that virtual and
the games that we want to play in that
so there is definitely that feedback in
that virtual and real world just like we
talked about earlier that delineation is
becoming smaller and smaller
why do you think it is that our own
self-perception our own sense of self is
so heavily impacted by the local social
environment even if that environment is
virtual why would that be adaptive
if you think about the environments that
we used to live in you know they're very
different than we live in now they're a
small local Villages communities we knew
everybody
um we would want to be in a hierarchy
there there was a level of status just
like we see in all animals so we lived
in small communities
so this is a system that's been
that's evolved through Millennia of that
type of an environment and now all of a
sudden all bets are off you're no longer
competing against 50 or 100 people that
lived in your small village you're not
competing against hundreds of thousands
of people online you're competing in a
global market and that seems
overwhelming at times and it doesn't
help that are
evolved systems aren't
selected to compete in that kind of a
world that's why I think
um our interactions in the social
environment online
through things like Twitter Facebook
Snapchat and all those things have such
a huge effect on us because we normally
had those kinds of interactions on a
very small local scale where we knew
everybody but all of a sudden this is a
global scale where we don't know
everyone and that person's getting more
likes than I am and I want more likes
that's not fair and it's a very weird
kind of competition where these
companies have drawn out all these
evolved kinds of behaviors that we have
and put them in a completely different
context and taken advantage of them
going back to the uh combat thing that
you were talking about earlier on do
beards provide an advantage during
combat
I that is always a fascinating thing
because in the literature
um there's been so
many arguments for why beards exist
and you and I are both bearded men and
they were born I'm growing this
beautiful handlebar guy at the moment
the people that are just listening I
look like a Miami cop from the 70s and
if you look at mine I'm starting to go
gray everywhere but this handlebar oh
yeah so you know I'm we look like we
both of us look like
I'll take it I'll take it
but okay in the literature yeah and the
literature is a funny thing
men are trying to explain why beards
exist and they start talking about you
know they're more attractive they hide
your jawline
um to make you look like a more
testosterone male uh and the the most
interesting one that uh a colleague of
mine found Barnaby Dixon was this idea
that beards are really good because if
you got hit in the face beards could
potentially
act as a
you know just kind of support your face
a little bit and maybe fist slides off
and you don't get that hit as hard in a
way they're insulating your face from
that full-on hit that you would get
and if you think about that if you've
ever found someone's beard like this
isn't going to insulate against anything
let's be honest this tiny little beard
if I get hit in the face I'm going down
the best that you can hope for is mild
irritation like a rash on the knuckles
of the person that's hit you yeah but
this is this is huge in the literature
and there's lots of people talking about
it and Barnaby is like this is enough
there's got to be a way to answer this
question so we looked at a bunch of UFC
fighters and you if you notice UFC
fighters change their facial hair all
the time
um sometimes they're bearded sometimes
they're not sometimes they have a
mustache sometimes they have a goatee
have all kinds of beard shapes so you
can actually score their beard shapes
um from you know one to five based on
nothing it's a mustache to a goatee to a
full beard to a heavy beard you know
score all that then you can look at
their wins and losses against
individuals that do or don't have beards
not only that you can look at their
likelihood of getting knocked out and
you would think if beards are good at
insulating a punch individuals with
bigger beards would be knocked out less
and they're not
it just doesn't happen so
I know so everyone out there if you're
growing your beer to make sure you're
insulated from a good hit it's not gonna
work this mustache was my prophylactic
against someone trying to assault me in
the street actually that was first off
because I want it to look like a
and the second thing was that I wanted
to not get not get knocked out so I well
I've definitely seen
um some evidence that that suggests uh
men who have beards are perceived as
more masculine perceived as more
dominant perceived that they would be
more likely to win in a fight the same
thing goes for the lower vocal pitch the
same thing goes for uh greater brow rage
for uh people that are smaller etc etc
more muscle mass uh shoulder to waist
ratio
um so even though
beards may not provide any physical
protection in a fight or in a contest
which has already been pre-agreed that
it's going to happen as a deterrent
I imagine that it must be effective
and that's that's a very different thing
again right and just like you said at
the beginning of what you said this it
changes our self-perception that it that
seems to be you know a recurring thing
we keep coming back to it and my
research keeps coming back to as well
if you put in a bunch of men in a room
they are really quickly able to figure
out a general hierarchy of where
everybody sits
it's fascinating kind of stuff
they jump into a room they don't know
anybody and they generally get a feel
for where they sit in that hierarchy of
individuals in that room amazing somehow
our self-perception and our experience
of on perceiving others who are of
similar traits gives us the ability to
understand where we sit and like I said
that's a great thing because that
reduces our likelihood for that physical
confrontation physical confrontations
are bad they're horrible like I said
earlier you're going to get injured if
you get seriously injured there's the
possibility that you won't be able to
attract the mate so
all across all animals what we end up
seeing is these really kind of these
contests that follow us very strict set
of rules let's look at each other let's
determine what's going on you display I
display we take turns we figure out
who's better if we're still not sure
after displaying then we escalate that
display and maybe start physically
touching if we still can't figure it out
only then do we actually get into a
physical confrontation so basically the
uh the justification here is most of the
Weaponry that humans and every other
animal has is used as a deterrent the
goal of the Weaponry is not actually for
fighting
it is you don't want to do this because
the risks for both sides even if you do
have the bigger Weaponry are still
pretty high
um absolutely but you have to develop
that Weaponry because if you don't
you're at a huge disadvantage precisely
yeah and it has to be a costly signal
right it can't be something that's
easily faked or else that's exactly
you're just going to test it exactly
yeah you use the word in one of your
studies contest competition
I learned about this
months ago and I can't remember the
distinction between contest competition
and some of the other different types of
competition can you just give me a
primer on that again
oh man I'm not even sure I can give you
that
so yeah so what do you mean by contest
competition you
so there's definitely differences
between contest and competition and
competition is that is that what you
mean did I speak to about this David
points David putz oh yeah okay was who I
spoke to about this okay what was I
talking to David putz about uh male male
aggression has driven a lot of the
sexual dimorphism that we see between
men and women the traits have been
developed to be effective at dominance
and aggression right okay so I think
this is to do with
um female mate Choice looking at
um basically allowing allowing females
to select guys off the top
um and contests contest competition will
be a different form of their selection I
see what you mean yeah yeah sorry David
puts speaking about the masculinity
thing David putt told me this story this
really funny story from when I think he
was a grad student who stood in line at
a check out some super
these two guys talking behind him and he
couldn't believe how low the voices were
they sounded like a Chocolate Rain kid
from sorry 2006. and um he couldn't
believe how low their voices were and he
turned round and he saw that there was a
really attractive girl in between him
and them
and right got him onto the men modulate
their voice uh based on whether there
are women around them
um if you have a um
if you have men looking to cross the
road
and women are present the distance
between the car and them is way shorter
than they would be prepared to accept if
there was no women present uh what was
the other one that he told me about so
there was the the lowering of the voice
oh that was the other thing that um your
vocal pitch basically acts in deference
to the status or the Potential Threat of
another male that's with you so men will
tend to actually raise their vocal pitch
when they're talking to a man of much
higher status and they will lower their
vocal pitch when they're talking to a
man who's of equivalent status usually
because if you raise your voice up a
little bit and you kind of talk like
this yeah I'm no threat you don't need
to worry please don't smash me into the
ground I am that's right Chris
absolutely yeah precisely yeah so I
thought that we were of similar status
another study another study that uh you
did that I thought was great was about
basketball players male and female
basketball players tell me about that
yes
um
so there
you know
you know we talked a lot about male and
female performance you know in these
worlds uh where we're talking about
physical performance men largely out
compete women
and and it makes sense right if you're
going to put a man and a woman uh the
average man an average woman in a 100
meter race the man's gonna end up
beating the woman and that's simply
because of differences in musculature
differences in bone structure
um physiology and all the underlying I
still have a lot of psychology right you
know when you look at
um uh bull throwing sports like
three-year-olds have got seven times
more throwing accuracy male to female
you know like you this you've been
around for three years this isn't
socialized you haven't hit puberty yet
it's driven by androgens in the womb but
it's also driven by protein folding in
the brain and what is it uh children
that are 10 years old you can detect
with a 90 accuracy whether it's a male
or a female just from the brain scan so
you know there's and this is just I know
that I've derailed the question I
literally asked no that's okay
um this for me is the most compelling
combat the most compelling talking point
to push back against trans uh M to f
female uh male to female athletes going
into female sports and it's because all
of the conversation that people usually
get caught up in is to do with how much
bone density do you lose if you've been
at estrogen for a year and oh you know
look at the power output differential
and blah blah blah and people that oh
but the structure and the size of the
hands there's differences in the length
of the forearm that makes it better for
growing and all of this stuff to me is
icing on the top of the cake that is
what is the mental capacity of the
athlete that I'm looking at what are
they actually good at and um David Geary
you familiar with David
yes yes yeah so David did this great
study he at least told me about a great
study
um where some
uh University researcher used a tennis
ball machine to fire tennis balls at his
students and instead of catching the
students who are actually trying to
dodge the tennis balls and this is that
this is that spatial rotation thing
again but it was it mediated for
catching and um the the males were able
to apparently Dodge the tennis or
whatever the basketballs are something
relatively easily and uh the female
students less so uh apparently it's
quite an old quite an old study I
imagine that you wouldn't get away with
them
I was going to say the same thing I
couldn't imagine getting the ethics to
be able to do a study like that anymore
yeah my just my point being
um you know and this is for every person
that gets into a discussion about you
know should we have like M to F uh trans
athletes in sport uh I think that the
most compelling argument by far is that
there's different fundamental
psychological capabilities if you wanted
to have M to f
ail to sorry female to male uh athletes
in a sport that was to detect lying or
that was to remember cards that have
been turned over on a table and to have
to match them it's unfair local uh
memorization uh cues of uh emotion and
stuff like being able to detect lying
women are going to wipe the floor with
the average man and Elite women will
wipe the floor with almost any man so I
think you know all of that stuff makes
sense but that's my that's my current
sort of uh contribution to to that
discussion now when someone says okay so
what what's the solution here what do we
do with trans athletes in sport I think
that's a really really difficult
conversation and I I yes I feel I feel
bad for people who not only are going
through you know a challenging gender
identity but then also want to play the
sport that they love and give them terms
of pleasure and I'm saying a number of
people are saying well you know you
can't do it that way but you also you
can't stay in the one that you're in
that's that's challenging however I
think that there is sufficient evidence
to suggest just like let's let's treat
um allowing them to go into whichever
gender category they now identify as
with a good bit of caution
yeah there is and if you
if we look at what when we often think
about men and women we think about them
like this right
um
this is this is where men are this is
where women are but the reality of
there's distributions across both of
those things right there's going to be
variation around
if we talk about means yes men and women
are different
but if we look at those distributions
they overlap quite dramatically
so even if we're talking about things
like memory or competitive ability and
we're thinking about transports where is
this individual that's transitioning
from FM or M to F where do they sit in
that distribution they may already sit
in more of a male distribution in
certain traits uh if they're if they're
transitioning from F to m
they are or vice versa right we do know
that both men and women demonstrate
traits of the opposite sex and these are
huge spectrums so one of the problems
that you have within Sports though I
think is that yes a lot of the not only
extremes but also the key drivers we're
talking about hand grip strength does no
crossover upper body strength crossover
yes it's two contributions and I think
that the same thing goes broadly for for
like some of the psychological
especially when you roll them out into
sweets you know if you take an
individual trait conscientiously but
then let's roll agreedleness on top and
let's roll this on top and let's roll
that on top and you can go again getting
more complex this is the signature of a
man yeah okay okay you you did a study
looking at basketball players what did
you learn
so we wanted to see how individual
performance changed over time you know
you can imagine that individuals
when they're younger they're great you
know you've got a lot of energy you've
got a lot of strength you haven't
seenessed this much so you just haven't
aged as much so your body just isn't
breaking down as much
and um what you find is that's generally
the case in men male basketball players
if you look at their performance in
various skills over their lifetime what
you end up seeing is that men generally
hit a peak I can't remember exactly when
that Peak is at this point
um but they hit a peak and then they
start senessing and start performing
more poorly
which is what you'd see in a lot of
non-human animals as well they hit this
peak and then you start aging and you
just not able to attract as many mates
or be able to protect your Harem any
longer you know Red Deer and elephant
seals are really great examples of that
you're the king at some point where you
have all the ladies and then after that
there's just somebody who out competes
you and you just don't do as well
so we did the same thing in female
basketball players because you know the
nice thing about the NBA and the WNBA
you have a lot of data for a large
number of years and you can start
looking at how individuals are actually
performed
what we end up seeing in women is they
don't actually hit that Peak
they don't seem to seness in their
performance like men do
now there's caveats in our data of
course the WNBA hasn't been around for
as long as the NBA quite yet so it's
hard to tell if if we start seeing the
same amount of data as in the NBA could
we see those differences and secondarily
you know women the WNBA doesn't have as
many teams that means that women aren't
playing as many games so their bodies
aren't on under as much stress
potentially
because they're not playing as many
games and traveling as much so maybe
they we don't end up seeing that Peak
because women aren't pushed to their
limits like men are in these really uh
these in the NBA where they're playing a
lot more games
and that may be true
nonetheless it's quite interesting that
men are hitting their performance Peak
at some point and then finesse and women
generally jumped and it can keep
performing for much longer until they
retire and choose to stop playing
without trying to account for some of
the ways structurally that this could be
explained away
why what is your hypothesis yeah
testosterone we know testosterone is
damaging
um so it could be physiological in that
sense where you know we're selecting for
aggressive strong men playing the NBA
and these men likely have higher
testosterone levels as a consequence at
some point that starts breaking things
down in our bodies and has that negative
effect where we just start senescing and
our bodies just can't repair themselves
as well to keep functioning in that
really great way in that necessary way
women don't have as much testosterone
testosterone as a consequence maybe
things aren't breaking down as quickly
or as strongly for women so we don't see
that happening uh in in female
performance over time so that's a
possible idea as well but of course that
needs testing so that would be the
mechanism
what's the Adaptive reason
hmm
well you know
not everything has to be adaptive
you know I think the reality so I I I'm
gonna believe I'm gonna put forward a
theory that I think that this is but
I'll let you okay so
we on we know that
men want to be in the hierarchy
if there's an advantage to having
testosterone to ensure that you're
higher in the hierarchy that's going to
be selected for
we know that
once if we look at the average you know
lifespan of a male that's increased a
lot over time we're a lot older now and
we we're living a lot longer now than we
did you know in 10 000 years ago for
example and that's for a number of
different reasons
if there's selection for testosterone to
be able to improve individual
performance and then we hit our Peak at
about 40 and then we start senescing
I'd like to think it's a little bit
later than that because I'm older but
anyway uh hitting 40 and then we start
senessing ten thousand years ago we
weren't living to 40.
right so there was no benefit to be able
to select for late life benefits
as a consequence that section would have
been very strong to maximize performance
to the age of 40.
and that means you're doing really well
after that it doesn't matter because
you're either going to be dead and
you're definitely not going to be
reproducing and you're definitely going
to be all competed by somebody else so
it's irrelevant you're essentially dead
at that point reproductively speaking
because you're not going to get a chance
to mate with anybody
that's changed obviously now right where
individuals are living for much longer
but that system that's been selected for
still exists and as a consequence we
Sines at that age at that point because
that's the system that we've evolved to
have and that's just how we work
well you have spoiled my theory because
that's what I was going to say yeah I uh
I uh it just seems it seems to make
sense the burnbrite accumulate States
right it loads as much as possible you
know 17 18 19 years old you're some
prehistoric killer everybody thinks
you're the running around
impregnate hope to stick about for you
know 10 12 years so that you can do a
bit of pair bonding and protect the the
one woman that you've got and you're
three kids or whatever and then they'll
be fine you know they'll be they'll be
fine so whereas for women you know
grandmother hypothesis for why menopause
exists
um women and also women on average live
longer than men like just even now women
live on average absolutely absolutely
and this is this is not well it'll be
contributed to but the risky Behavior
thing is only going to be a partial
contributor to this it's just that
women's longevity seems to be more
effective than than men's so yeah I
think um
that's an interesting one that's an
interesting way to
to think about uh
why men sort of burn burn everything a
little bit brighter and a little bit
quicker
um and yeah you know Downstream from
that you're going to have some
physiological impact yes let's say that
um you have 100 units across your
lifetime of athletic ability to deploy
men are able to squeeze more of that out
yeah they're sealing from which they can
draw uh is going to be higher than
women's because it is in their interests
to try and accumulate that status to
accumulate that
um and then you know do the reproduction
thing but the mums need to stick back
and they need to then become
grandmothers and they need to become
aunties and they need to become sisters
and and so on
um
one of the other things
considering the changing modern
landscape for uh dating online how
that's changed the way that people go
about things as well
didn't you do a paper that looked at
mate guarding the modern world and how
mate guarding had been adjusted weren't
you involved in something to do with
that I was not but that sounds really
interesting your name's down your name's
down and something if you look at Google
Scholar closely enough
uh-oh which paper do you know the title
of the paper by chance no no I'll have
to pull it up but I mean dude look face
it your your age index is going up it's
going up through the roof
um I think the the other one that I saw
seemed an awful lot like
um who's that who's that Australian
researcher the blonde lady that you did
your you've done this bloke and this
Blake thank God yes uh dude I've had so
many female Eve psych researchers on the
show over the last 12 months I basically
everything everybody is just blended
into one very interesting episode
um so Candice did some interesting stuff
that looked at how economic inequality
predicted sexual objectification like
the post yeah sex and selfies and you
did something that looked at national
income inequality predicting women's
preference for masculinized faces yes
what yes what what's that why is it
better than health explain that to me
yeah that that was an interesting study
that I was part of um and I was lucky to
be part of it so a paper came out and
said on a global kind of scale they
looked at you know can we start
looking at in math how masculine men
look and can we correlate that to the
amount of disease within that social
environment and the idea here is that
individuals have
um more testosterone in an environment
where you're more likely to get sick are
showing off good genes because
testosterone is damaging it's a costly
trait and if you're pumping resources
into
creating testosterone and creating large
jaw lines and the signals that are
associated with increased testosterone
that means you must be so good
that because you're also able to survive
an environment that has a lot of disease
because and then wow you must be a high
quality male because you can do all
those things
so you must have really really great
genes
and that's a a wonderful idea and that's
that idea is lived in the non-human
animal literature for a really really
long time and we talked about it a lot
until we realize that it doesn't work
there are much more proximate
explanations for what's going on
um and those proximate explanations
explain things much better than these
underlying genetic potential
explanations explain that
yeah so
if you think about
if you for example if there are you and
I and a bunch of other males uh in an
environment we're competing for females
and we're we have
um big Jaws uh and traits that good
mustaches good mustaches thank you very
much and beards thank you I appreciate
that
um then those are all signals to
potential mates and if we're in an
environment
and those signals potentially show off
our good underlying genes that we have
very strong genes and that's really
great
the problem with that is if females end
up mating with us yes they'll get our
good genes but at only 50 percent of
those genes
they may not be the right genes because
of how you know uh DNA works and all
that and we don't know how those genes
are actually going to interact with
others
so there are potential benefits there's
no doubt to that
but if you and I have a lot of money and
we have a provide a safe environment
and you know we have a lot of access to
a lot of resources that's a direct
benefit that females gain from mating
with us because they have access to that
immediately and that immediate benefit
outweighs that potential genetic benefit
because that's more long-term and isn't
as clear-cut
so what we did in that study is we said
all right yeah sure that could be a
potential explanation but we feel that
there is a simpler more immediate
explanation
and that's just the fact that in those
environments that have a lot of disease
around
um where there is potential for social
unrest
there's a benefit to being around males
who are bigger and stronger because they
can potentially protect you from that so
it has nothing to do with the genes that
they Harbor it's just the fact that well
if you hang with me I'll make sure
nothing bad happens to you and you'll
get all the resources you need and
that's immediate that happens now
without having to reproduce and that's a
stronger benefit
that women can gain immediately and
that's why that has such a stronger
effect
that's fascinating man very very it's
cool stuff but it's it's the it's the
inequality thing yeah it's like I I am I
missing something there
no I don't I don't you know it's
again it's tied to our culture and
that's why I say that you can't separate
those kinds of things in those countries
where there's more social and rest and
there's more disease they're likely not
as developed they don't have the
medicine they don't have the resources
the populations may be higher uh the
risks are greater and that's part of the
environment not to do with lack of
development right it's to do with
inequality specifically or at least
that's what it that's what it says here
so let me yes I'm gonna put my yes my
bro signing hat on again yeah yeah go
for it and this is from Candace Blake's
stuff um what she said her justification
was
um
in areas that have higher income
inequality uh women post more sexy
selfies they do more sexual
objectification blah blah blah
her reason for that was that when you
are in an area of high economic
inequality as a female you are able to
see both how high you can rise and how
low you can fall and what it gives you
is this explanation or this example of I
don't want to go there I can't go here I
don't want to go there what are the
tools in my Arsenal that can allow me to
get up this ladder that I can attract a
higher value mate
so a study that looks at income
inequality predicting women's preference
for masculinized faces would suggest to
me that they
presume Downstream from the masculinized
face is a greater protective provider
who is more likely to get them away from
the life that they've been exposed
because it's not just exposure to the
high flying life it's also exposure to
the underclass life that they want to
try and avoid and I think it's both the
motivation to run away from something
you want and the desire to run towards
uh something that would be desirable run
away from something that you don't want
sorry and run towards something that's
desirable yep absolutely you're right it
is the inequality and that inequality is
is often
um it's tied very very strongly to sex
uh you know men and women
if we look at different societies and we
look at you know the gender inequality
index we see that varies quite a lot
around the world and
yes I would agree that in that
environment where there are more risks
uh there are likely more gender
inequality and women will behave in a
way that maximizes their likelihood for
Fitness so I'm wondering I'm it was just
national income inequality income
inequality between the Sexes or income
inequality between most wealthy and
least wealthy between the Sexes oh
yeah I right I throw my entire the last
five minutes of what I've just spoken
about
so don't throw that away at all right
yeah we needed no we uh well of course
yeah yeah yeah of course it would be
that if you as a woman are less capable
of earning your own way you are more
reliant on the man the masculinized face
of the man is a predictor of protective
provider therefore exactly right fine I
mean that's that's that's actually
relatively straightforward
it is but it's it's really interesting
and it's great that you say It's
relatively straightforward because I
totally agree but it's interesting that
people went the first explanation was it
must be good genes they must be those
high quality genes that those women want
in that environment to be able to get
them out of there and again that's not
direct when that direct benefit of
having access to that individual and the
status that they hold is much stronger
when you say direct but what you're
doing is you're looking at someone's
face and presuming from their face how
much money they earn so I mean it's it's
like relatively direct compared to good
genes hypothesis and sexy sun but it's
not that it's still relatively
convoluted it's just that we see we
don't see code right we just see Matrix
we see the actual simulation look Mike
let's bring this one home mate this has
been really really fantastic uh uh good
fascinating I had a blast you do good
where should people go if they want to
keep up to date with the things that you
do why should they head on the internet
well you know we're I'm doing some fun
stuff now
um
if I can I'd like to mention that I
started a company a few years ago and
the company's actually gotten a little
bit larger it's called our little and we
create games that help people explore
more about the natural world and we've
created games that help people
understand how individuals behave
towards one another
so these are all little mobile games and
apps that individuals can download
teachers can use to teach in class and
you collect data really really quickly
the key is it allows students to do the
stuff that we just talked about over the
last hour or so and you can start
exploring data start understanding the
human world a little bit better start to
understand our own brains and our own
minds a lot better because I think what
needs to change like we talked about a
little bit is our is you know our
environments change so dramatically over
the last hundred years
that our culture our culture has as well
and that intersection between those two
things is still coming to a head so we
can better understand how we should kind
of be behaving in society and towards
one another and I think people can get a
better understanding when they start
reading more when they start interacting
and engaging collecting data running
experiments seeing individual behaviors
because then you start getting to
understand a lot more about how our
bodies behave bodies and brains behave
automatically because some of the stuff
that you talked about about Candace's
research and our research and what I
think is most fascinating is all this
stuff is happening automatically it's
not like in Canada's study for example
that girls are thinking well I know that
I'm in a really kind of lower economic
area and I see that women over there in
that lower economic area are showing
more skin I'm going to do the same
because they seem to be successful
it's just automatically happening
that's the key and if we start
understanding what's automatic what's
not when it is when it isn't we can get
a better understanding of ourselves and
our society and you know I think we'd
start to really get a
you know start answering all those
societal problems that we have because
we're being a lot more honest with one
another where should people go if they
want to check out more of that
and check out the website our ludo.com
and all our games are free to download
and you can play them and uh yeah get in
touch with me there and I'd love to help
teachers teach the next generation of
kids to better understand themselves in
the world around them oh yeah Mike I
appreciate you thank you yeah absolute
pleasure thank you so much Chris I had
an awesome time what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
face